thank you
[Music]
all right
go ahead make a judgment I can't see
avoid costly mistakes who is this woman
is she a real estate agent make your
judgments go ahead what judgments I
don't have to what are your judgments
costly mistakes can you share your
judgments so I could be on your team
yeah what are you talking about I'm the
news anchor I'm gonna share the story
I'm gonna share nothing but the facts
here okay okay she's talking about
something to do with uh loans and
mortgage is she a finance professional
oh this better not be a mortgage video
no it's not a mortgage video
it better be an only fans [ __ ] ad
that woman has been accused oh oh here
we go of drugging and killing her
stepdad after finding naked photos of
herself on his computer whoa
it's like a [ __ ] version of Batman
yeah taking matters of their own hands
oh fighting his own Justice
made it serious how does he have naked
photos of her secret camera problem hey
why are you over there [ __ ] snooping
around lady
yeah there's no property are you [ __ ]
stupid around this [ __ ] that's what
happens so her name is Jade Jinx uh
she's an interior designer age 39 she's
been arrested in San Diego accused of
drugging and strangling Thomas Merriman
age 64. I was gangster New Year's Eve a
hand-to-hand combat death yeah dude
drugging and strength
[ __ ] dude Thomas he don't sound like
no player you know what I mean that guy
don't know how to do it right that's an
unarmed kill prosecutors alleged Jinx
killed Merriman after she saw he was
using one of her nude photos as a
screensaver this guy sucks
they're in the middle of a conversation
and then the the computer goes to sleep
and then her [ __ ] naked photo shows
up like this dude this guy probably
[ __ ] was gonna show her on Amazon
they got this deal on them oh sorry
[Laughter]
Thomas is is that me on your screen oh
no uh yeah it's because uh [ __ ] all
right I'm just gonna let the cat out of
the bag I downloaded off of your [ __ ]
computer dude what the [ __ ] is wrong I
didn't even get her [ __ ] maybe he
subscribed to her only fans downloaded
it and then he posted it on it from one
of her boyfriends oh the photographs
were reportedly taken more than 10 years
ago and were consensually taken by Jinx
and her boyfriend it isn't clear how
Merriman came to get a hold of him this
guy's good I know [ __ ]
like it smells like oh wait so he
smells like so he got it when you're
like
guilty one just made a right turn wait
so step dad like her husband's dad or is
it her like is it like a a a stepdad as
in like her mom remarried that's a
father-in-law oh father in law yeah
never mind yeah bother me I met remade
okay okay
so the prosecution alleged she called a
friend to help her but he told her he
didn't want to get involved the
following day he went to the police to
tell them what happened
oh [ __ ] hate right what a snitch bro
the lead detective in the case Lisa
Brandon said in court Miss Jenks told
the friend that she killed her
stepfather and she said I suffocated him
with a bag and I choked him why why is
he a rotten ass [ __ ] that's lame she
did her homie her friend yeah and she
asked to help
okay but also let's say like I killed
someone and I told you you can get in
trouble now yeah you can go to jail you
can do some jail time if you don't say
[ __ ] though really yeah dude yes because
then you know information you withhold
information to like the authorities
prayed for your life though that's one
way to get out if I could be like I love
that ride you lie so much
[ __ ] wild it looks like he's been in
this situation before but this is all
natural he's like
all right dude I'll get it you can tell
you snitched he's got snacks in this
book let me tell you something I'll tell
you exactly what happened boy you gotta
cut me a deal man
he does have someone
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
I may remember what happened a little
better you know
no but um
well that's why I think like if somebody
tells me
I mean you know but I'll be like I don't
know what the [ __ ] you're talking about
and also I'll be like that's a funny
joke
it's like you're joking right yeah
you're saying you're joking allegedly
and I'll be like cool dude right away if
somebody's telling me like you [ __ ]
hold on dude you did what exactly you
did what
you crazy dude you're [ __ ] insane
Dude tell me again one more time
[Music]
so wait wait you [ __ ] you you killed
someone just break that down what did
you do Step by Step At the beginning
four o'clock I'm not a part of this but
it is
going to shoot me I see a gun in front
of me could be a water gun I'm not sure
I don't want to risk it but yeah dude
that sucks for the friend too you know
you just put her in a situation yeah
yeah totally prosecutor said James found
the phones uh or found the photos when
she was cleaning her stepfather's
apartment while he was in the hospital
she is alleged to have sent a text to a
man about giving pills to my man it read
I just dosed the hell out of him
stopping for whiskey then at Dixieland
to stall let me know in another message
Jinx allegedly wrote he's waking up I
really don't want to be the one to do
this and then another said I'm about to
Club him on the head as he's waking up
um
why'd she have to kill him though
I mean could you not talk to him
could you not tell him hey you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] and I don't want nothing
to do it because what was her and I'm
gonna sue you
oh how did you get those photos and are
you jacking off to me yeah exactly yes
maybe she didn't want to confront that
conversation but definitely I don't know
why the killer well let me tell you
something a good plan of disposing the
body let me tell you something right now
dude yeah also yeah but a screensaver
though I don't think it was about it her
plan wasn't to dispose a murder victim
her plan was more so like that he died
of other causes outside of her hand is
she that smart to be able to pull that
off that's my question like top
difficulty if you yeah exactly like if
you're gonna kill somebody and you have
motive
like you have to make sure you doesn't
have the skill set because she's an
interior designer that's what I'm saying
he's looking at curtains what if she hit
his body really well in the house so
they're like whoa I mean if there's a
staircase in the house but that's about
it but I mean it's to me it's amazing
that's true that's true dude we all have
a [ __ ] like last straw right that's
her last straw and that was her last
draw
that's her [ __ ]
[ __ ]
right yeah she's just like putting
things in her hands because here it goes
here wait hold on what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] that and she goes and [ __ ] does
some crazy [ __ ] yeah that's a pretty
crazy reflex the only never thought
about confronting like this that you
just go straight to that murder but
there's a paper murder but there's so
much like Trail to her like leading her
yeah there's drugs in his system isn't
thought out very well but then she just
went off of emotions
her attorney says Merriman died due to
his failing Health in a cocktail of
sleeping pills he had taken right he
takes a [ __ ] records the attorney
said quote the medical examiner will not
tell you with strangulation the science
does not support strangulation as the
official cause of death was recorded as
acute intoxication the attorney claimed
Merriman was an alcoholic and had an
addiction to sleeping pills so I guess
oh the corner corner basically huh he
said his client loved her late stepdad
who he called a troubled individual Jay
Jinx loved her stepfather Tom Airman
loved JJ's unfortunately Tom Merriman
was a troubled individual and he loved
her in different ways even though the
text mess messages sound really really
weird bro she sent those text messages
very Woody Allen of her it's a Woody
Allen case
I like the idea though that when
somebody has a last draw their first
words
you're not casual I mean what the [ __ ]
hold on she was obviously on the phone
yeah hold on let me call you back what
the [ __ ]
[ __ ]
and she sees herself bouncing as on the
screen saver
dude and she just wanted to kill the guy
yeah who
keeps a nude for a screen saver well
it's probably that screensaver that's
linked to a picture folder oh like the
Ken Burns effect that like just like any
photos that happen to be in a little
slideshow everything in there I'm really
proud that he did that himself he's like
oh you know I made the screen over there
at the Racquet Club at the [ __ ]
locker room is like yeah hey Todd come
here
look what I got holy [ __ ] is that your
stepdaughter this is a [ __ ] hey it is
[Laughter]
watch this one watch this one holy [ __ ]
instead of her [ __ ] vagina yep
I got all of them hey send me that in
fact no way are you kidding me
crazy that's my stepdaughter you're
talking about
[Music]